[Music]
now our major ET exclusive carter thick
the 19 year old son of growing pains dad
Alan Thicke is opening up for the first
time about the day he watched his father
collapse at an ice rink and Carter's
only talking to our special
correspondent Keltie night he was like
the perfect dad anything I ever needed
he was there for how often did you play
hockey with your dad Rick to the net
maybe like twice a week those were
probably some of the best memories with
him Carter was right there when Alan
suffered a heart attack on this hockey
rink in December
Alan collapsed but never lost
consciousness he was even joking with
his son and told him to snap a photo of
him with the EMTs what was that moment
like that was kind of a moment of relief
for me that's why the obviously how that
day ended was a quite a shock the
ambulance came and the paramedics had
stabilized him and everything seemed
fine he was back to joking classic coz
every because I've been at a couple of
his emergency room situations when his
lung collapsed I was there and every
time he's made me take a picture of him
because he thinks it's hilarious for
some reason he thought it was funny that
in that state he looked so funny thought
it was hilarious and he'd send it out to
a ton of people and so yeah he asked me
to take a picture of him in the
stretcher and you know he's telling all
the EMTs to smile and put the thumbs-up
and you know he was cheery and and I'm
happy and doing well so I took the
picture did you have any sense he wasn't
feeling well was he sick before no uh he
was hilarious in the locker room full of
life very energetic he didn't seem like
he was out of shape or anything so you
were completely shocked completely
shocked I had no idea what was going up
the 19 year old college sophomore looks
just like his dad around the same age he
recalls Alan's final moments what's the
last thing he said to you after the
thumbs up did he say anything else um no
I followed him to the emergency room and
the last thing he really said to me
before going to the operating room was
he's being morbid as it usually is and
he said oh got to play hockey with my
son and got to watch him score goal what
a way to go out and then you know before
he went to the operating room I got to
give him a hug and said I love you and
then that was last time I saw
[Music]